PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
IT NOW SEEMS TO BE A MATTER OF
WHEN, NOT IF, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL AUTHORIZE THE RELEASE OF A
CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED MEMO ABOUT
ALLEGED SURVEILLANCE ABUSES BY
THE FBI.
EXACTLY WHICH VERSION OF THE
DOCUMENT WILL BE REVEALED IS
ALSO A SUBJECT TONIGHT.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE BEGINS
COVERAGE BY TELLING US WHERE WE
STAND.
>> AFTER THE OTHER OF BRUTAL
RECRIMINATIONS IN THE CALL FOR
THE REPUBLICAN HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
TO BE REMOVED, THE WHITE HOUSE
SIGNALED THE MEMO'S RELEASE IS
IMMINENT.
>> WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WE WANT THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
AND KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> WHITE HOUSE AT THE MEMO WAS
UNDERGOING A FINAL NATIONAL
SECURITY CHECK AND THE
PRESIDENT'S SIGN-UP.
INTELLIGENCE FOCUSED ON FOLKS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> TRAVELING FROM THE G.O.P. OR
RETREAT IN WEST VIRGINIA, SR.
WHEREAS OFFICIALS THAT THEY WILL
TELL CONGRESS PROBABLY FRIDAY
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS OKAY WITH
IT AND WHICH ACTIONS ARE
UNLIKELY.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE DEFENDED
THE PROCESS AND CHAIRMAN OF
>> I THINK THEY WOULD LOVE
THROUGH A REAUTHORIZATION OF 702
WHICH IS A FOREIGN TERRORIST,
FOREIGN SURVEILLANCE LAW.
FOCUSING ON KEEPING THE COUNTRY
SAFE, FOCUS ON NATIONAL
SECURITY.
I THINK THAT WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO IS SIDETRACK US.
>> DEMOCRATS DRAFTED THEIR OWN
VERSION AND CAME OUT SWINGING.
>> THE ULTIMATE DECISION IS MADE
BY THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN HE READS THE MEMO FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND SHOWS THE BOOK AND
MEMO IS FLAT-OUT FALSE MY GUESS
IS HE DOESN'T AUTHORIZE ITS
RELEASE.
>> HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
NANCY PELOSI WENT FURTHER,
CALLING FOR THE CHAIRMAN'S
REMOVAL.
SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID THE
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSWOMAN --
HOUSE COMMITTEES RAKING DEMOCRAT
ADAM SCHIFF ACCUSE REPUBLICANS
CONGRESSIONAL RULES DISQUALIFY
THE RELEASE.
ADAM SCHIFF SAID THE GOAL WAS
UNDERMINING THE SEPARATE SPECIAL
COUNSEL OPTIONAL PROBE.
>> BECAUSE OF SERIOUS AND
MATERIAL OMISSIONS, IS
INACCURATE AND GIVES A VERY
MISLEADING IMPRESSION.
DESIGNED TO TAR THE FBI AND THE
DESCRIBING THE EDITS IS MINOR,
INCLUDING GRAMMAR.
AT LEAST TWO CHANGES ARE MADE OF
WITH THE MEMO'S RELEASE
APPEARING TO BE CERTAINTY, OR
COMMITTEE REPUBLICANS TRIED TO
TAMP DOWN EXPECTATIONS.
>> I THINK OF HER BOOK AND
SOMETIMES MAKE A MISTAKE OF
OVERSELLING THINGS.
IT'S VITAL AND ESSENTIAL FROM
THE PUBLIC TO SEE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE OUT THERE.
>> FBI'S STATEMENT WARNING OF
THE ACCURACY PUTS DIRECTOR WRAY
AT ODDS WITH THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS.
THE FBI AGENTS ASSOCIATION
RELEASED A STATEMENT THINKING
DIRECTOR WRAY FOR STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
AGENTS.
SPEWING WATER RELEARNING ABOUT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL FOCUS ON THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
>> MEDIA REPORTS THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS FOCUSED ON